- [Voiceover] In the video
on competitive inhibition,
we saw that competitive inhibition
is all about a substrate
or a potential substrate,
an inhibitor competing
for the enzyme.
And whoever gets there
first, gets the enzyme.
If the inhibitor gets there first,
then the substrate isn't able to bind,
and of course no reaction is catalyzed.
If the substrate is
able to get there first,
then the inhibitor isn't able to bind,
and the reaction does get catalyzed.
Now the inhibitor and the substrate,
they both might compete
for the active site,
if we're talking about
competitive inhibition.
But you also have allosteric
Where they're still trying
to compete for the enzyme,
whoever gets there first, gets the enzyme.
But the inhibitor doesn't necessarily bind
at the active site, they
bind at an allosteric site.
But it's the same idea.
If the inhibitor gets
to the allosteric site
before the substrate
gets to the active site,
then the confirmation
of the protein changes,
so that the active site, you
know it changes a little bit,
something like let me
draw in that same color,
the confirmation of the
protein changes a little bit.
And then the actual intended
substrate isn't able to bind.
If the intended substrate binds,
then that changes the
confirmation a little bit
at the allosteric site,
and then the inhibitor
isn't able to bind.
So if that's competitive
inhibition, where there's like
who gets to the enzyme first,
what is non-competitive
inhibition all about?
Well let's draw that.
So, non-competitive inhibition.
And the big picture here is that
they can both bind.
Whether one binds to the
enzyme doesn't affect
whether the other binds.
So let's talk about it a little bit.
So, this is my enzyme.
That's my enzyme, right over there.
And what we have happening, of course,
is if the substrate's able
to get to the active site,
then of course the reaction
is going to be catalyzed.
And we saw that up here.
Substrate binds to the active site,
and then the reaction is catalyzed,
in this case the substrate got broken up
into two other molecules.
But in non-competitive inhibition,
what happens is a substrate can bind,
and so can an inhibitor.
And the inhibitor can bind
at an allosteric site,
so this is our inhibitor right over here.
The inhibitor can bind
at an allosteric site,
and when they're both bound,
notice they're not
competing for the enzyme,
they both can be on the enzyme.
This character can bind
to the enzyme whether
or not the substrate is there.
But if this guy binds to the enzyme,
the substrate can still
bind to the enzyme,
but now the reaction
isn't going to proceed.
So now the reaction is
going to look like this:
so now there's not going to be a reaction.
If this happens, the only
option is that they both unbind.
So now this character is just going
to leave the active site.
No reaction has been catalyzed.
So, it just prevented
anything from happening.
And maybe this guy leaves as well.
And the way I showed this
non-competitive inhibition,
I showed it happening
at an allosteric site,
the inhibitor attaching
but it actually doesn't even
have to be the same case
as long as it does not prevent,
it can actually bind close
to or even at the active site
as long as it does not
prevent the substrate
from binding to the active site.
So you can even have
a situation like this:
this is the one that's typically given
for non-competitive
inhibition where you have
the inhibitor binding
at an allosteric site,
but the idea here is that both of them
can bind to the enzyme.
If one of them binds first,
then the other one can still bind.
If the substrate binds first,
then the inhibitor can still bind.
If the inhibitor binds first,
then the substrate can still bind.
But, the reaction is not
going to be catalyzed.
But you can even have a situation
where the inhibitor and the substrate
can both bind in or
around the active site.
So that's the inhibitor, and
then this is our substrate,
this is the substrate.
But once again, this reaction
is not going to occur.
We have non-competitive inhibition.
They're not competing for the thing,
they can both bind to
it, whether they can bind
isn't dependent on whether
the other one is bound,
but if the inhibitor is there
then it's not going to allow
the reaction to actually be catalyzed.
As opposed to competitive inhibition,
whoever gets to the enzyme first,
gets the enzyme.
Hopefully that clarifies things.